et has learned kanye west is newly
single but he kept plenty busy on social
media this valentine's day including
some controversial posts about ex kim
kardashian and her romance with pete
davidson e.t reached out to kim's rep
for comment just do something for my
heart on monday the rapper kicked things
off sharing these photos the images
seemingly show a truckload of flowers
kanye delivered to kim's house he wrote
in the caption my vision is crystal
clear later kanye shared these
screenshots of text messages the
conversation is allegedly between
himself and kim and they concern his
repeated comments about pete you just
gotta roll with it the first message
reads you are creating a dangerous and
scary environment and someone will hurt
pete and this will be all your fault
kanye wrote alongside the snapshot quote
upon my wife's request please nobody do
anything physical to skeet i'm gonna
handle the situation myself
in another post kim further explained
her concerns allegedly writing there are
dangerous people out there and this is
scary and it doesn't have to be
seemingly in response to kanye sharing
screenshots of their messages kim later
allegedly asked why can you keep any of
our conversations private kanye reacted
by
well sharing an image of kim's alleged
complaint about her privacy he also
replied to the question writing because
i got a text from my favorite person in
the world i'm your number one fan why
wouldn't i tell everyone i call him my
boyfriend and he calls me his girlfriend
earlier on monday et learned kanye and
julia fox are going their separate ways
after dating a little over a month a
source told e.t the two are quote no
longer together you kind of like connect
the dots kanye how are you
how are you doing today oh what up baby
how you been
good you with the babies today
enjoy enjoy
kanye's social media marathon comes the
day after he attended super bowl 56
stepping out with his eldest kids north
and saint
we got good seats dorothy
kanye donned an all-black look while
eight-year-old north and six-year-old
saints sported football jerseys for the
big game and that glove right there that
was given to yay by la rams player odell
beckham jr who tossed him a pair before
taking the field
[Applause]
meanwhile jonathan chebin one of kim's
besties recently voiced the et his
support for the new relationship as
kim's one of kim's closest confidants
what do you think of her and pete
together um i think it's cool you know
what she's having fun i guess you know
uh you know i i've hung out with them a
couple of times and
you know i love her to death so whatever
whatever makes her happy ask her friend
how are you supporting her through all
the kind of the kanye craziness that's
happening i don't even know anything
about that so i love kanye too man he's
a genius excuse me um but you know
listen i just i hope i hope everybody um
ends up settling